Emperor Palpatine will return in Star Wars
Episode IX: The Rise of Skywalker, and he
won't be stopping by for a cameo despite what
actor Ian McDiarmid might say:
"I have to be honest with you: I was in the
area, so I thought the least I could do is
to pop in for a laugh."
All joking aside…
Speaking with IGN at Disney's D23 Expo, stars
Daisy Ridley, John Boyega, and Kelly Marie
Tran offered some insight into the importance
of the dastardly figure who was famously thought
to have perished at the conclusion of 1983's
Star Wars Episode VI: Return of the Jedi to
the flick's story.
Fans were shocked when Palpatine's distinctive
laugh was heard at the end of the first teaser
trailer for Rise of Skywalker, and it was
made explicit that this was no misdirection
when the movie's first poster was revealed
at D23.
"No one's ever really gone…"
(laughs)
The poster features the Emperor's visage floating
above Ridley's Rey and Adam Driver's Kylo
Ren as they face off in a lightsaber duel.
In the same way that his likeness looms over
the poster's imagery, Boyega astutely pointed
out that Palpatine's machinations loom large
over the entire Star Wars series.
He explained:
"I think the Emperor and his doctrine has
trickled down to so many of the characters
in the Star Wars universe, and that the Dark
Side [of the Force] is what it is because
of a lot of his actions and plans.
And so, to have him come back, he's like the
greatest foe, and greatest enemy…
I mean, we might as well take him down properly."
Ridley similarly called attention to the importance
of the character to the overall narrative
of the Skywalker Saga, and assured fans that
his reappearance after seemingly having met
his end at the hands of the redeemed Anakin
Skywalker was not a plot development that
was taken lightly by the filmmakers.
Ridley said:
"He's the biggest baddie in Star Wars history…
now that we've done the story, I'm like, it
couldn't have happened any other way.
Like, it had to be that.
But he's very, you know, instrumental to the
plot of the film.
It's not just like he appears again; it's
all explained."
Asked about her take on the way director J.J.
Abrams and company brought the epic nine-film
saga to its conclusion, Ridley said:
"I think it's awesome.
When we were doing it, I kept going, 'Oh my
god, this is so cool.'
And that's nice to be in a film where you're
actually saying, 'Oh my god, this is so cool.'"
For her part, it seemed to be all Tran could
do to keep from spoiling the entire movie.
She said:
"I mean, I think that there are so many themes
in the Star Wars films… my favorite being
redemption, and this idea of, like, whatever
comes at you, you can… well, I'm not gonna
give you, I'm not gonna tell you what happens,
but… the theme of redemption."
Pressed on exactly what her comments meant
in regards to Palpatine, Tran grinned mischievously
and said, quote, "Look, I don't know."
Of course, the stars were also grilled over
Rey's seeming transformation in the new footage
from Rise of Skywalker which was screened
at D23.
Said footage saw her cloaked and hooded, wielding
a distinctive, Darth Maul-esque red, double-bladed
lightsaber suggesting that before it's all
said and done, the character could be taking
a walk on the Dark Side, a development which
could be strongly tied to Palpatine's return.
Their responses were right in line with their
previous remarks: Boyega's was cheeky, Tran's
was carefully worded, and Ridley's was downright
evasive.
After the apparent "Dark Rey" reveal, Boyega
quipped:
"For me, it's just a mere costume change.
I mean, the girl wanted dark.
I wear black sometimes, doesn't mean I'm bad.
The red?
It's a glow stick thing."
He also added,
"I don't think the fans should really get
into all of that.
What you need to look at is how C-3PO got
his golden arm back… that's the question
for me."
Tran, when asked about the reveal, offered
up this cornucopia of vagueness, saying:
"I think the most important thing to take
from that whole snippet is just that the ending
of this film is going to be really… really
groundbreaking, in a good way.
I think there are a lot of little pieces from
the older films, and everyone's together in
this one, and it's a really big… we're gonna
go out with a bang."
Ridley, while no more inclined toward specificity,
did tease that Rise of Skywalker will revisit
the themes of the previous films in putting
a bow on the Skywalker Saga.
She revealed:
"I think [the movie] should, hopefully, show
people that we did a big old journey, and
we explored some things.
So, just you wait 'til the film [comes out]."
Thank you for stating the obvious.
To find out for sure how Rey and friends wrap
up their story, we'll just have to wait until
Star Wars Episode IX: The Rise of Skywalker
hits theaters on December 20.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Star Wars
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.